this is not a surprise we expected this
i didn't think
anyone was going to offer eli manning
the kind of contract that would make him
leave the giants and feel that he was
going to be the guy
wire to wire in 2020 that would take 20
million or more
i didn't think that was coming he didn't
think that was coming
he's not interested in changing teams no
one's out there interested in making him
their guy for this year so he retires
that's right nfl legend and you know
it is time for eli to retire and i'm
glad he is retiring
and i say that you know almost i say
that selfishly
but only because out of respect where i
just go man eli manning's a giant that's
what he is
i'm still in miami chris i went to the
game and it
was awesome i'm sure it was awesome
watching it on tv and it was awesome to
be home and i'll be home later today but
i wasn't missing this one
this was one of the best ones i wasn't
sure it was going to be
i didn't think it was going to be i
didn't think it was going to be a great
fourth quarter and then all of a sudden
it was
yeah well it was the whole spectacle of
the super bowl first off was special
after the second interception mahomes
was eight of 13 for 114 yards
two touchdowns no picks a 129.5 pass
rating
forgetting about that performance that
did have him
and you mentioned it i mentioned it last
hour on radio he would have been the
goat in a bad way yeah
if that doesn't turn around with those
two interceptions and he just forgot
about it and he moved forward and he got
it done and as you mentioned
came back from a 10-point deficit in the
fourth quarter that's only happened
three times in a super bowl chris
and two of the times kyle shanahan was
calling the plays on off
with the coronavirus here in the united
states clearly spreading who knows how
long it's actually
been here there will be an impact on the
sports world sooner or later and
probably much much sooner the nfl told
me on sunday that it's closely
monitoring developments
and has been in contact with the world
health organization cdc
nfl pa medical experts and
those at the duke infection control
outreach network
program for infection prevention that is
one hell of a mouthful
but um they're going to continue to look
at it throughout the off season here's
the thing
the draft is 51 days away i don't know
what's going to happen with this
nobody knows what's going to happen with
this and i have not even the
the shred of qualification to wonder
what may happen
the end result no one is going anywhere
for the draft everyone will be at home a
virtual draft announcement made by
commissioner roger goodell yesterday
in a memo sent to all teams in response
to developing conditions and the advice
of medical and public health
experts clubs have been advised to
prepare to conduct
the 2020 draft entirely outside of their
facilities and
in a fully virtual format with club
personnel in separate locations and able
to communicate with one another
and draft headquarters by phone or
internet we want all nfl personnel
to comply with government directives and
to model
safe and appropriate health practices
the big news
obviously is the vikings signing a new
long snapper no
it's the tampa bay buccaneers landing
hashtag tommy
from the new england patriots it came
down to the buccaneers and the chargers
brady chose the buccaneers
and you know it's been a combination of
the patriots saying goodbye with
billboards all around the new england
area
but it's also been a hello by the tampa
bay buccaneers
what can you want patriots fans more
than 20 years and six super bowls
with one guy it ain't gonna last forever
he's playing three years
max anyway and who knows what kind of
skills he has now
in comparison to what they were but if
somebody is upset
who should they be blaming chris well to
me you're right i mean first off it was
it's been the greatest showing we've
ever seen between quarterback and head
coach so
let's all just appreciate that before we
start blaming
you know one guy or the other and i
understand that's the business we're in
you know i think okay if you're gonna
make me blame
one guy i'd probably put a little more
blame on bill belichick
but i don't necessarily sit here and go
all of it goes on him
i would go like 52 belichick 48
brady i think brady deserves some of
this as well you know
i think brady unrealistically is asking
for you know
respect and wants to enjoy his job and
that's just not
in the dna of a guy like phil belichick
he's always the general
it doesn't matter how many super bowls
you've won he's always looking for the
next one
receiver deandre hopkins thought to be
available in trade
chris i had heard last year that one of
the sticking points between bill o'brien
the coach of the texans and brian gaine
the former
gm was that o'brien wanted to trade
hopkins
and gaines position was like the rest of
us are you crazy
well now with gain not there hopkins on
his way to arizona
and the texans picking up david johnson
the texans also giving up a second round
pick wait the cardinals give up the
second round pick the two teams flip
flop
fourth round picks your reaction to the
texans pulling the plug
on one of the best receivers in football
well i you know i've heard you say
you know that before about the the
things you had heard last year
uh i heard the rumors out there that
people thought deandre hopkins might be
on the trading block i i i really did
not think it was going to happen
i really did not now i do think it's
kind of a win-win as far as
x's and o's are considered for each team
i do
i mean the texans have a huge need at
the running back position
david johnson really fills two roles in
one
because he is a phenomenal pass catching
back which makes him
a first and second down between the
tackles type runner
but then also can do the things we've
seen out of
new england running backs for years
right because billy o'brien that's the
offense he runs dion lewis james white
whatever
david johnson is like a slot receiver
when it comes to the pass game
so i'm sure they looked at it like that
the core message
not what you want to think the message
is the core message
of the treatment of african-americans
and people of color by police
it's it's we're seeing the consequences
yeah it's still a little relevant
here's what happened if george floyd
doesn't get murdered last week we're not
going through
any of this stuff right now yeah no
no not that not that that would have
been look there's still a problem that
needed to be addressed and maybe we were
just one more
one more death away from it exploding
but that but that's the point
it's the build-up of years and years and
years of this kind of thing and this was
the one that provided the tipping point
and kaepernick was trying to get our
attention to it
before it hit the tipping point four
years ago chris well yeah
he was you know and sadly enough it's a
very relevant conversation still
and we see it a few times a year at
least so
yes i mean what colin kaepernick was
fighting for mike you and i have talked
about this a million times
we're all in we're in the fight with him
there's no doubt
i mean we support everything that he was
that he stood for
you know i've talked about it on the
show many times before too just my
experiences being a quarterback in the
nfl
listen i've seen some of these social
injustices in person
and things like that they are real uh it
is very commonplace in our country
just two days ago there was one player
who had exercised the privilege to opt
out of the 2020 season
as a concession to the pandemic and the
concerns that players have the health
issues they may have
the family issues they may have and it
was one guy
and there were people around the league
who were speculating and estimating as
of monday that
the ultimate total of players who opt
out would be in the single digits
well as of right now there's more than
25
who have opted out chris and it's been
one after another
after another after another and a bunch
of patriots are out
it's serious i mean the fact that we
don't want to see the replay
no tv station wants to show you it tells
you how bad it was his leg collapsed
i am scared he is a guy that's
predicated on movement and doing those
things
and mike brown you know zach taylor with
that talk mike brown's got to be so
pissed off
the rule the the rule of the year was
just to get through the year with joe
burrow healthy
and they floated with danger all year
long in that category it's a shame for
doc prescott
i really feel for the guy i really do
um yeah i can't imagine i really can't
and you know you're just in a big year
of his career
we don't know how serious the we know
the syria the injury is serious i just
hope it's not any more serious than what
we think
ligaments down there yeah right that's
what i worry about that's what i worry
about
because it's not like he's you know
mobile mobile but he certainly uses his
legs and uses his power
that's very big full quarterback exactly
well that's what got him hurt
it's the power right he's got a db on
him all right
and he's so big and strong that most
quarterbacks would just crumble and go
down and be like oh i give up
right yeah he's kind of like i think i
can throw you off me and keep running i
was saying there weren't a lot of days
um
when i didn't i didn't think it was
going to happen um
but you know you just kind of keep
pushing through you know and i always
felt like
uh when i had my darkest moments there
was always something around the corner
that happened
that i just kept kept kind of plugging
along and all of a sudden i made a big a
big gain
for a big step or something clicked and
you know and then i kind of keep
marching and
you know and i felt like it would repeat
itself and all of a sudden though then
i'd make another
you know another jump um and for me
obviously the biggest ones have been the
last you know six eight weeks you know
just getting out on the field and really
doing it and knowing that i can and
doing it consistently
it was a moment i i i just wish that the
stadium had been full so he could
receive the proper
gratitude and appreciation for the
inspiration that he's provided
in coming back from arguably the worst
injury we've ever seen
all those surgeries infection that
nearly claimed his leg and his life
and he never gave up his family in
attendance
imagine what they've gone through
constantly worrying about
when is everything gonna be the same
again when's dad gonna be the same
is dad ever gonna be the same is dad
gonna live um
it's just just a great great story and
an inspiration to anyone who needs a
lift at any time because he's been
through it worse than anyone has been
through it
[Music]
[Applause]
hey let me tell you i hope to never be
in that position but i would pull that
damn bell off the wall
if i ever got to the end of that kind of
a journey and uh
um so anyway it was it was great to it
was great to see that
and uh here's hoping that it is the end
of the journey
you know you never know with something
like this but the treatment's over
and uh he goes forward and he barely
missed a beat
and and his team is a half game out of
first place in the nfc east which sounds
a hell of a lot better than saying two
and five
it just gives me chills mike and you go
back and you think about yesterday and
how hard washington played
and how hard dallas didn't play and they
almost looked like they quit and i
kept thinking about that thinking if
you're washington how do you quit on
this head coach
i mean what he's gone through a missing
practice
missing some meetings and just gutting
it out having ivs at halftime of games
to keep going
murray is unbelievable and he just
showed it on that freaking play once
again
every quarterback in football gets
sacked there where he was i mean
basically
you know other than maybe lamar maybe
josh allen can get
get out of there but marielle addison
the rush they did a good job for the
most part all day long kind of
containing him as far as
when it was a pass play and he had to
scramble and extend plays
but he's just so elusive and
strong and he's just his speed to the
edge and then the setup to throw it
and when he when he left his hands and i
saw it was hopkins and i went oh man at
first it was just him and two guys i was
like
you can ask the guys in the viewing room
yesterday i went oh man quite honestly
you know we're not where we want to be
as an offense
we know that and you guys have heard me
say this a lot
around here in the five years that i've
been here and it's it's never about one
person and
um you know we won a championship a
couple years ago with with a group of
men and it's
it's never about one guy he's out of
time that's it they got to see what
jalen hurts can do congratulations
jaylen hurt you get to do it against the
saints defense yeah right i mean yeah
yeah
what would he do you get to play the
hottest defense in the game right now
he's been kicking everybody's butt but
maybe that's part of the reasoning too
maybe that's where you know doug
peterson looks at it and goes
hey the stuff we've been doing and you
know the offensive attack we've been
approaching each game with and the way
carson went we got no chance if we play
that way in this football game
well listen i've been saying this since
monday i thought this was the right move
i do you know one it's just the the
pylon effect for carson wentz right now
it's all everybody talks about and
especially in philadelphia
i mean darius light gives up a touchdown
on a 50-yard bomb they go oh carson
wentz
you know i mean it's everything it's
carson wentz's fault for
everything so there is that issue we've
talked about it i do think he's beaten
down
by the pressure the scrutiny everything
about that
and yes the offense does stink and maybe
jalen hurts can give that spark right
the dolphins got to their goal of
winning the game because
for the second time during the starting
quarterback career of ricky tuatonga
viloa
who took over after ryan fitzpatrick was
benched tango by law during a game
benched and in came ryan fitzpatrick
and it worked so now the question is
what should the dolphins do brian flores
the coach of the team shireen has
already said
two is a starter i think the leash is
going to be shorter now the more that
you do the fitz magic routine
the quicker you're going to have people
on the sidelines
looking at flores then what are you
putting in fitzpatrick
if tuatanga by loa is struggling and for
tonga by loa the challenge is not
constantly looking over at the sideline
after every mistake
saying when's he gonna be when's he
gonna take me out i i credit tonga by
lower for being sufficiently mentally
tough
to not crumble in the face of that but i
just
don't the thing that i love about this
it's great
it's different it's fun but it doesn't
seem sustainable
let me also say this can i apologize to
devonte adams for not having them my top
10 wide receiver list because
uh that was probably my most egregious
mistake
uh of the past year as far as football
wasn't
i don't know i think it was i think it
was i'm sorry my lists have been pretty
damn good
my draft evaluations are pretty damn
good but he
is on fire right now and playing
phenomenal football
i think right now the vikings would say
if they could
undo the trade they would say we're fine
because they're happy with justin
jefferson who's on the way up
the bill's got digs when he was already
at or close to the top had the ability
to be one of the best receivers in the
nfl just needed to have the ball thrown
his way
more frequently by someone who had the
ability to get him the ball more
frequently and whether it was
disenchantment with the vikings
run-based offense or disenchantment with
kirk cousins
he recently admitted that it was not in
his best interest to be in an offense
that was going to run the ball so much
although i think cousins played a role
in it but diggs has been
incredible look at this first in targets
with 158
first in catches with 120 and 1459
receiving yards 191 per game over the
last three weeks
gives him 21.05 which is significant
because it's the single
season rushing record if he gets it or
gets close to it
how does he not get mvp votes chris so
we're we've focused on mahomes and
rogers just like in 2012 we were focused
on peyton manning
and then here came adrian peterson with
the late push
i just think that if if henry can keep
it going
and and it is a big if but if anyone in
the nfl can do it it's derek henry
he is going to have i think a legit
chance to maybe flirt with 2
000. i don't know if he can get to 2100
and the all-time record and all of that
but either way i'm with you
he deserves to be more talked about in
the conversation
and for me when you just talk about the
pure essence of mvp
you know yeah it mahomes rogers josh
allen
and derek henry they they they are the
epitome of that and i think that
that makes a lot of sense but i'd like
to see him flirt with that 2000 and
get close they're going to be far better
off with trevor lawrence
but but mission accomplished for the
jacksonville jaguars they're going to
have trevor lawrence
and if trevor lawrence is as good as
advertised the teams in the afc south
are going to have to deal with this guy
for the next 10 years or longer
yeah no definitely i mean i would i you
know i look at trevor lawrence and i
think
um a lot of like it's this is justin
herbert it's a very similar
guy to me in a lot of ways except this
is a guy who
you know probably even a little more
athletic than justin herbert in some
ways i don't know if he can throw it the
same way herbert's pretty special throw
in the football
but it's that type of guy the pittsburgh
steelers will host the baltimore ravens
finally we think wednesday afternoon 3
40 p.m eastern week 13 scheduling
changes so lots of early prime time
football next week because of the
midweek
raven steelers game and look chris
what happened yesterday and we wrote a
story about this
that really caught fire and within a
half hour the nfl moved the game
baltimore players were threatening
to refuse to play the game tonight
not because of covet 19 concerns but
because of
their own physical safety resulting from
the fact that they haven't been allowed
to practice
they haven't been allowed to prepare
you're going to throw these guys to the
wolves that are the pittsburgh steelers
with 20 guys unavailable with a bunch of
backups and slappies thrust into play
with no chance to get ready to play
after being shut out of the facility for
a week
they had real concerns about their own
safety they were not ready to go forward
with the game
and they were considering refusing to
play and that leveraged the nfl into
moving the game to wednesday
i had so much soul i'm hungry now it's a
game that's going to go down in history
it was like the scene of a movie i mean
if you wrote a movie about this
people wouldn't believe and i see him go
down and i'm like we gotta start man
we just gotta go out there and you can
see lamar trotting back out on the field
it was
you know like jeez i don't want to go
down the moral
victories we lost got the
see the ball kicked the ball
automatically he did the rest i was
cramping
i ain't putting paul pierce last night
was
awesome it was last night was special
and uh there's there's so much i think
we've budgeted the first hour of the
program just to talk about this game
chris there's so much to talk about
yeah well there is and you know like
just to get out ahead of your
conversation there
it is different to me than the chiefs
rams football game you know that game
that that had moments and plays of like
oh there's a guy catching the ball
nobody's in the screen touchdown and
then it was like
three plays later the other team answers
nobody's in the screen
touchdown this was at least sustained
drive
smash mouth football at times yes it led
to some big plays
and it led to you know two teams
answering each other a bunch here
throughout the football game but
i i didn't have as much of a i didn't
have a problem with that is what i'm
saying and i you know me i'm a fan of
the 2824 football game that's my
favorite type of game but this was
fun to watch had a little bit of
everything still had hard-hitting
defensive plays
but oh my gosh hi i'm mike tarico and
thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports